[Musica]
d
dovete fare una cosa
chiudete gli occhi
chiudete gli occhi e pensate alla vostra
città ancora più difficile in questo
contesto lo state facendo
fatelo vi prego se io penso alla mia
città che torino mi vengono in mente due
immagini una e la griglia delle strade
geometriche a torino era un accampamento
romano in origine e l'altra è una
immagine presa un po dall'alto in cui si
vede la città e le alpi attorno a perché
torino è circondata dalle montagne e da
un fiume dall'altra parte italo calvino
ha chiuso gli occhi e ci ha raccontato
55 città diversa e 55 città immaginarie
55 bozzetti nelle città invisibili le
mie due preferite sono zora la città
geometrica calvino dice una città che
quando l'avete vista non la potrete mai
più dimenticare e moriana la città che
quando la vedete vi sembra fatta di
alabastro e cristallo luccicante ma
quando entrate nella porta vedete il
cartone delle periferie
un po come tante delle nostre città
avete ancora gli occhi chiusi
potete riaprirli se volete e nel farlo
però provate usare gli altri vostri
sensi quando siete in città
usate l'olfatto cosa cosa annusate il
rumore del cibo dell'individuo del del
cibo dell'immondizia che cosa
ascoltate la musica che esce dalle case
oppure soltanto rumore del traffico e
sulla pelle cosa sentite il caldo il
freddo il vento che magari da un po
fastidio le città aggrediscono il nostro
sensorio sono piedi stimoli sono piene
di stimoli che che noi dobbiamo
interpretare con le nostre architetture
cognitive e cerebrali e per come siamo
fatti alcuni di questi stimoli
diminuiscono al nostro benessere perché
gli esseri umani stando bene in
condizioni climatiche di un certo tipo e
non in altre
soffri 26 gradi abbiamo caldo la nostra
traspirazione funziona bene tra il 40 e
il 70 per cento di umidità i rumori
sopra i 100 decibel non soltanto sono
fastidiosi ma sono anche dolorose
se prolungati e possono anche essere
dannosi e le città sono piene di queste
cose
per questo che più difficile stare bene
in città ed è più facile stare bene in
un posto come questo che pure aggredisce
i nostri sensi ma lo fa in maniera molto
diversa
ora a cortina stiamo mettendo in piedi
un progetto per costruire un'immagine
del benessere di chi viene a cortina del
benessere cittadino del sensori urbano e
lo stiamo facendo utilizzando come
strumento questa panchina
un arredo urbano semplice che però può
diventare anche una componente
tecnologica ora un piccolo passo
indietro
cortina è una piccola città a 5.700
abitanti che però è anche molto grande e
molto grande perché il suo territorio
copie 250 chilometri quadrati che
comprendono tutto quello che abbiamo
intorno in questo momento è molto grande
perché durante i periodi di massimo
afflusso turistico
arriva fino a 40.000 abitanti più grande
del capoluogo di provincia belluno che
ne ha soltanto 35 mila da un punto di
vista urbanistico in una delle
caratteristiche di cortina come di molte
città di una via principale forza italia
che inizia a monte da piazza fratelli
ghedina e arriva fino all'incrocio a
valle con via roma corso italia come
sapete uno dei baricentri della vita di
cortina ci sono i negozi c'è il comune
c'è la chiesa ora ci sono anche le
panchine le panchine sono disposte lungo
corso italia e oltre ad avere un ruolo
funzionale d'arredo urbano 15 si può
effettivamente sedere sopra si può anche
ricaricare il cellulare e la seduta è
riscaldata e poi hanno degli schermi che
forniscono informazioni ma non sono
soltanto panchine sono piattaforme di
raccolta di dati
queste panchine sono dotate di sensori e
questi sensori misurano una serie di
misure la temperatura l'umidità
l'irraggiamento solare il rumore
abbiamo quindi tre isole sparse lungo la
via che ci consentono di capire che cosa
accede in quella microcella climatica
ora vogliamo utilizzare questi dati che
però da soli non sono sufficienti
attorno a questi abbiamo costruito una
fusione di altri dati dati di contesto
dati che ci ha fornito la città insieme
al suo ai suoi al suo main partner dati
che ci danno un'idea di quello che
succede da un punto di vista
meteorologico tutto attorno ma
soprattutto di quali sono i flussi
turistici di quante persone sono in un
certo momento in città
di che cosa stanno facendo in funzione
degli eventi che vogliono che sono stati
organizzati
abbiamo quindi dei dati microscopici
raccolti da queste tre isole digitali
abbiamo i dati di tutto il territorio e
che sono quelli raccolti alla pubblica
amministrazione su questi aggiungiamo
della tecnologia della tecnologia che da
un lato vuole costruire dei modelli
delle persone che sono presenti in città
chi sono cosa fanno
quindi quali sono le loro attività e
quali sono i loro aspetti democratici e
dall'altro vuole produrre in uscita
un modello che mettendo assieme queste
informazioni climatiche possa dirci se
queste persone in quel momento stanno
bene oppure male per fare questo oltre
ad aggiungere questi dati utilizziamo
quelle che oggi sono le abbiamo
reclutato le più innovative tecnologie e
quindi un approccio basato su machine
learning non supervisionato per
costruire per far emergere dai dati così
come sono
quali sono le strutture sottostanti e
soprattutto quali sono le correlazioni
tra quello che le persone fanno e quello
che il clima in quel momento ci sta
dicendo
questo perché perché è evidente che a
seconda di quello che fate
avete una condizione di comfort diversa
prendete un caso semplice il caso della
guida se state guidando evidentemente la
visibilità di una delle variabili più
importanti ma che diventa ancora più
significativa se ci aggiungete per
esempio l'informazione se sta piovendo
se sta nevicando se c'e del ghiaccio
sulla strada
tutto questo assieme produce un modello
che potrà essere utilizzato anche dal
decisore pubblico per pianificare
attività o per misurare qual è l'impatto
delle attività che sono state
predisposte
quindi alla fine qual è l'idea mettiamo
insieme dei dati aggiuntivi per avere
una frazione della città che non sia
soltanto visuale anche se noi siamo
molto guidati dalla vista abbiamo gli
altri sensi e gli altri sensi
contribuiscono l'intero sensorio
contribuisce al nostro farci stare bene
o farci stare male e dall'altro lato
forniamo uno strumento aggiuntivo a chi
fa pianificazione urbana per andare
verso quegli obiettivi che ci stiamo
ponendo ormai tutti come abbiamo detto
più volte rende le nostre città più
confortevoli più vivibili e
possibilmente anche maggiormente in
grado di superare le emergenze
e tutto questo lo stiamo facendo anche
grazie a una panchina
grazie
[Applauso]